HE'S WON HIS LAST ONE UPSIDE.
IN THE TRAFFIC FROM BERGERON,
FINDING HIS WAY BACK.
A -- IN.
THE POSSIBLE ANGLE.
ABLE TO LIFT ONE OF OVER
SHORTSIGHTED GOAL, PUTTING THE
GOALTENDERS DOWN.
WHO HAVE MADE MORE MISTAKES.
HI
THE SEASON.
BRUINS SHOULDER
AND THEN, FOR T.J.
OSHIE ON
SCORING, CRAW
THE BRAND
OFTEN.
>> -- WAS THE -- ORTHANDED.
SCHOLZ, TYING UP --
DOES NOT GET A SECOND CHANCE
OPPORTUNITY.
HERE IGHTAWAY, JENSEN SHOT.
AND SCORE.
BIGGER THAN -- WE
FIRST ONE OF THE HOCKEY GAME.
10 FORWARDS IS GOING TO BE AN
INTERESTING FORWARD.
THE THE 1.ER.
THE PUCK,
IT IS A GREAT DRIVE HERE.
A3-THREE HERE.
YOU HAVE BERGERON WITH THE AFTE
PICKING UP MORE BOTTLES SINCE
YOU BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
BRUIE
SPINOZA, FINISHES.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE ENTRY.